une première médicale au canada des
chercheurs ont découvert que des
cellules souches prélevées sur la peau
de souris pourrait permettre les mêmes
expérimentations que les celles ou ceux
que les cellules souches embryonnaires
ce qui pourrait évidemment résoudre les
problèmes éthiques que posent les
recherches sur l'embryon humain
explications avec delphine horvilleur
soigner des malades grâce à leurs
propres cellules
ces chercheurs canadiens commencent à y
croire leur espoir vient de ces souris
adultes et plus particulièrement de leur
peau c'est là qu'ont été isolés des
cellules souches
ces cellules sont capables d'évoluer
vers de multiples tissu des muscles et
des nerfs ou des tissus graisseux qui
pourront réparer des organes malades
on trouve ces cellules souches chez
l'embryon mais beaucoup plus rarement
dans un tissu adultes des cellules
souches et qui en plus facilement
évoluer vers différents tissus
voilà notre grande surprise c'est
essentiel pour tous ne pousse à croire
que ces mêmes cellules existe dans la
primaire si leur présence est confirmée
chez l'être humain cette découverte
constituera un espoir dans le traitement
de nombreuses maladies comme le diabète
ou la maladie de parkinson ou
d'alzheimer
ces cellules facilement accessible
permettrait de traiter un malade avec
ses propres tissus et donc sans risque
de rejet une nouvelle piste à explorer
pour les chercheurs oui non non nous ne
savons pas ce que ça peut donner
il est encore trop tôt donc nous ne
devons plus en plus autre avantage de
cette découverte
elle n'exigerait pas d'expérimentations
sur les embryons en pleine controverse
éthique sur ces manipulations
elle offrirait aux chercheurs une
solution alternative plus consensuel